[Music]
good evening mr. Nye my name is lucky
man blogger and I am super ballsy so I'm
sorry if I sound weird or look weird but
my question to you was on cold fusion
was it something I actually had married
or was it something that the scientific
community legitimately had reasons for
abandoning your thoughts please Loki
Loki Loki don't look that weird to us
sir you look fine
about a cold fusion so here was the idea
there's a guy who really had the first
patent on television was the mythic this
was really his name Philo Farnsworth and
it is said he told people that he had
the idea for television by plowing his
uncle's potato field as a as a kid and
he looked at the way the the furrows
went across the field and inferred that
would be a way to make a moving picture
that same guy got it in his head that he
could make neutrons do whatever he
wanted like he had this one success and
he got it in his head that he could
influence neutrons and he created a
device which he called a phaser and that
that word has later been used to
describe rotating vectors in electro in
light waves and heat waves but this
thing was going to enable neutrons to
fuse together at room temperature he was
not able to do it I mean this in order
to do that as far as we can tell right
now you need the gravity of a star which
we have at our nearby star the Sun and
people have speculated that you could
also contain fusion not speculated
that's an exaggeration in a magnet in a
magnetic field a very very strong
magnetic field but no one has been able
to build a magnetic field
powered by the fusion reaction
that makes the fusion reaction makes
enough power to to establish the
magnetic field strong enough to hold it
so that ever in my experience growing up
it's always 40 years from now when this
won't be done but recently an aircraft
company I guess it was McDonnell Douglas
claimed or yeah McDonald claimed that
they'd be able to make fusion happen at
room temperature I'm very skeptical
because I look at what happens in nature
with these stars but it's so far cold
fusion was a myth now then about 25
years ago 1988-1990 scientists at at a
university in the state of Utah here in
the US thought they had established cold
fusion that they had established a
magnetic field powered by the energy of
the fusion that would contain the
reaction but they didn't they had the
thermometer in the wrong place on their
lab equipment and I cite this as an
example of journalists who were not
scientifically literate enough to
question this out this result this
published result or announced result and
they just let the thing the journalists
let the thing spiral out of control to
the point with the story to the point
where somebody like you 25 years later
is asking essentially the same question
can we have fusion at room temperatures
as far as we know no however it is
reasonable that you will be alive when
people really do figure it out
it's exciting so very it's a great
question
[Music]